How many business records
are duplicates of other businesses?
To Fuzzy Match the businesses,
we attach the Fuzzy Match tool, and
then we select the purge mode, since
we're dealing with jus one dataset.
The ID field can be used as the record
ID, since it's unique to each record.
How can we be sure of this?
Well we can attach the unique tool and
see that no duplicates flow through.
No records can make the D side and
all the records come out the U side so
they're all unique.
Next we select the field that
contains the business names,
which is called account holder,
and then select the match style,
called company name as it
best fits with the data.
Lastly, we add the unique tool after and
select ID and
ID2 to eliminate duplicate matches.
There are three businesses that have
duplicates and they're identified here.